the annual purge will conclude in three  two one  [Music]  thank you for your participation  we survived all police and emergency  services have been reinstated  all crime including murder is now  illegal come on let's get to work  one night only rest of the year is  peaceful  help me help me  the purge is over please  no it ain't this is insane  nobody hear the sirens there's no crime  anymore  anything goes you rich can't hide behind  your steel walls no more  powerless how does that feel is the real  purge the forever purge  hurry up they're coming  come on follow me there's nowhere safe  to go  no way to get help oh my god  we gotta find another way to get out of  [Music]  here  this country's gonna collapse  mexico was opening its borders for the  next six hours let's go  we're in this together  does this translate  [Music]